hello and welcome to the 16th of a basic
hired Python I knew I was gonna do that
basic PHP tutorial in this tutorial
we're going to be discussing the include
and require commands and basically what
they're gonna do is they pretty much do
the same thing but if they can't do it
that's where they defer so the include
is gonna call for a file to be included
if it can't be included everything will
still run require on the other hand will
require that file whatever to be
included so to speak and if not then it
will it will cease to run so but the
actual command to do it is the same and
so in this sense what we're gonna do is
I've already got this header dot PHP
file since header two but it's actually
a header not quite sure why it's do it
because I have another header file or
something in this temp folder but
regardless it's corresponding to the
header dot PHP so for a header off PHP
we're just going to do h1 and this is
the website title and in fact so this is
the website title let's call this PHP
PHP support ok that'll be our header
we'll save that and we'll upload that to
the server so if we pop over to if we
pop to this we see this is the page this
is what's included with header it's just
you know h1 like with a header one tags
and we want that on this page so the way
that we do that is we'll pop over here
and you just say
include header.php now if in put it in
quotes if it is located in the same
directory then you put it there
otherwise you know you start using these
oops
it'll go within here like that if it's
in like one prior directory if it's in
another prior directory we'll do that
and so on but for now it's actually in
the same directory so we'll just leave
that there and now we're going to say
we're just going to echo out some
regular text and we'll save this and
we'll run this and when we refresh we
forgot our semi colon of course
now you see that we've included the
rules for our really a header file
and so the reason you'd want to do this
is over time if you have a website or if
you've ever visited a website in your
life you probably notice that the top of
the website is about the same no matter
what page you go to now if this was
hard-coded as in like typed out every
page like say this website wanted to
have like a little bit of a facelift and
use a new banner or something like that
they would have to like go through by
hand and change every single pages
header and that would be like really
tedious so instead what you do is you
just have include header at the top of
the script and what it'll do is will
just include that whatever the header is
so if you wanted to say you know what I
like PHP that's cool and tutorials well
what if what if we wanted to do like we
were like well dang you know now we're
we're like strictly like PHP video
tutorials right like you're like dang
that's like a way better way to describe
our site so so we'll do welcome to my
PHP video tutorials and say you have if
you had you know 50 pages you don't have
to edit this page at all you just edit
the header page and so when you save the
header page we'll come back over here
and now it's video tutorials and so if
you had like 50 different pages you
would be able to do this like really
really quick instead of having to go
through and edit them and just as a
quick aside since it is here we can say
require hetero HP and we'll upload that
and refresh and you know it's still
there so it's still working so it
doesn't really matter which one you use
if it's there but if you don't want the
page to break if it can't get that file
then you just say include so like if you
were including a PHP page or
script that had like an integral
function to the entire page and you
couldn't seem to get that you would want
to use that like require if it's
integral to the page working you want to
use it require that way you're not going
to continue running through a bunch of
code when you don't have the information
you really need right and you would want
to have some sort of error code or
something like that and then with this
another thing you can do is see let's
say like we did this what if we did
2includes so we include the header file
twice what happens then well this would
upload so we pop over here we run it and
as you can see you know it's included it
and used it twice now we can get rid of
that one so now the heck was I going to
show you over every right what you can
use is these two there's another
variation of these in functions or you
can say include underscore once and now
let's save it replay and now you see
even though we called it twice
it's only been displayed once because
what this include once does is it asks
the question has this already been
included if so nevermind and as you can
see it has already been included
therefore it did not include this one
same thing with require it could be
require once so and boy I wonder what
happens if we use require ones because
it hasn't been required it's been
included so now what oh man the suspense
it's killing me it is just killing me
and it only runs once so hopefully not
too many of you guys got killed by the
suspense so anyways that's the include
and require functions
as always thank you for watching and
until next time